من بيروت ينضم الينا المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الاتحاد الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا لويس ميغيل بوينو مرحبا بك سيد
لويس معي في هذه التغطيه على شاشه العربيه
اريد ان اسال اولا عن موقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي من ما حدث في الهدنه السودان
هدنه وصفت بان هشه تم اختراقها من قبل
الطرفين في اكثر من مناسبه
اولا شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه وتحيه لك
للمشاهدين الكرام نحن كنا نرحب بطبيعه
الحال باعلان هذه الهدنه من سنيه في
السودان بعد ايام من من الصراع ولكن صحيح
هناك اعلانات هنا هناك لاختراقات
وانتحاكات لكن نحن نريد ان نكرر دعوتنا
للاطلاق المتقاتله
لجعل هذه الهدنه الانسانيه لوقت لقد نار
دائم هذا هو المطلوب وكما تفضلت في تقريرك
هذه الدعوه يعني اتت لسودانيين وتم
اعلانها يعني من قبل الاطراف مختلفه سواء
كان لسعيد الدولي وساليد الاقليمي
فالمخطوبه الان يوقف النقل الضرب بشكل
دايمون لتاوله المخوذات هذا هو الموقف
الاوروبي ولنا قلنا مباشر المتقاتله في
هذا الاطار يعني انت تؤكد الان انكم
تواصلتم مع طرفي النزاع مع البرهان ومع
حميتي
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي اتصل
بالاثنين الجدرلين في هذا الاطار في اثاره
جهود الراميه من قبل الاتحاد وايضا من قبل
شركائنا الدوليين والاقلاميين من اجل واقف
اللقب وذلك ايضا في اطار يعني جهودنا من
خلال البعثه الدبلوماسيه اللي كانت في في
موجوده في الخرطوم بتربيه الحلا الان تم
نقل الموظفين الاوروبيين خارج السودان
ولكن هذه جهود مستمره بما في خلال المبعوث
الخاصه لهذا المنطقه اللي هي حضره اليوم
الجلسات في الاتحاد الافريقي
والتقم الرئيس المفوض الى تركيا في هذا في
هذا السبب طيب هل الاتحاد الاوروبي في هذه
الازمه على مساحه وعلى مسافه واحده من
طرفي النزاع في السودان
نحن نعتقد بان من المهم للغايه هذه خصوصا
في هذه الاوقات الحساسه نحن نمر بها انه
لا يكون اي تداخل خلينا نقول بشكل مباشر
لدعم
طرف او طرف اخر نعتقد بان الان المطلوب من
الطرفين المتسرعين هو وقف وقف القتال
والعوده للحوار كان هناك حوار لمده ثلاث
سنوات منذ اندلاع ثوره في السودان وكانت
هناك فتره انتقاليه صحيح ماليه بالتحديات
مختلفه وكما نرى اليوم تحديات كبيره
للغايه ولكن لا يوجد هناك اي حال عسكري
لهذا لهذا لهذه المشكله لهذا الصراعة هل
وجدتم استجابه من السيد البرهان والسيد
حميدتي بشان وقف دائم لاطلاق النار ام لا
لا يزالان متمسكان بالحل العسكري حسب ما
فهمته حسب معطياتي يعني في من خلال هذه
المكالمه بينهم وبين السيد بريل كان
الطرفان ملتزما
يعني اجراء
الاجراءاتها ببذل الجهود اللازمه من اجل
وقف اللق النار لكن على ما يبدو الطرفان
يتماسكان
بموقفهما في هذه الاوقات ومره اخرى هذه
الدعوه مفتوحه ومستمره للطرفان لوقف
القتال نعرف انه هذه يعني هذه الظروف صعبه
للجميع ولكن لا يوجد اي بديل لشوار في هذه
في هذه الحاله طيب ما الذي يخشاه الاتحاد
الاوروبي اليوم من تفجر الاوضاع في
السودان والتصاعد وتيره الاحتراب بين طرفي
الازمه
نعم يعني كان كابل هذه الاسماء كان يعاني
يا سودان من اسماء انسانيه مجريه يعني سيل
للغايه كان الاوضاع ولا يزال للاسف شديد
سيل للغايه في المناطق السودانيه نتحدث 14
مليون نسمه الذين يعانون ويعتمدون بشكل او
باخر على المساعده الانسانيه فبالتالي
هناك تضعيات واضحه للسيده الانساني كما
راينا خلال الايام الماضيه هناك
كذلك يعني اعتقد انه الدول المجاوره خصوصا
ستكون اكثر تضررا من الاتحاد الاوروبي في
هذا المجال عبرنا عن قلقنا بطبيعه الحال
يعني ازاحه التطورات يعني فيما يتعلق
بتضايات وانكاسات هذه
الاحاد الصراعها في المنطقه وخارج المنطقه
كذلك
مخاوف اوروبيه بالفعل هل تم اجراء كل
بعثتكم من السودان مواطني حتى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي بامان
تم نقل واجلاء الموظفين الاوروبيين اللي
كان شغالين يعني في مكتبنا في الخرطوم
بالاضافه الى
1200 تقريبا مواطن روبي من جميع جنسيات في
الاتحاد خلال يومين قبل يومين او خلال
الويكند الماضي الان هناك قليل جدا من
الروبينيين بكار البقيه في كم تبقى تقريبا
من اعداد الاوروبيين الموجودين في السودان
كنا نتحدث قبل هذه الاسماء تقريبا عن 1700
مواطن الان تم اجراء تقريبا 1200 فالبقيه
هي تقريبا 500 هل هناك تقديرات لموعد
اجلائهم من السودان هل سيتجهون مباشره الى
[موسيقى]
يدفعون اخل ثمن وهذا هو هو السؤال عن عن
ما بعد اجلاء
البعثه الدبلوماسيه لكم ما بعد اجل ايضا
حتى الرعايه الاوروبيه من السودان
والغربيين بشكل عام ماذا بعد عمليات
الاجلاء ما الذي تتوقعونه في السودان سيد
لويس نعم هذه النقطه لغايه العاميه وشارع
اليها الممثل على نفسه خلال تصريحته قبل
يومين نريد ان نقول بان قبل يعني بعد
عمليه الاسلاك سنترك السودانيين
ورائنا كما كما نقول بين قوسين صحيح انه
الظروف الحاليه صعبه ولا يمكننا ان نقوم
باعمالنا كالعاده تم اعتدال صفيرنا تم
اعتداء الام مسؤول المكتب الانساني في
السودان كذلك في الاتحاد الاوروبي
فبالتالي في هذه الظروف الصعب ان نعمل
بواجبنا ولكن رغم كذا كل ذلك نكون الوضع
بتنسيق المتحده لمواصله تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه
الملزمه لللازمه عفوا للمحتاجين ليس فقط
وايضا في مناطق اخرى وهناك
نيه واضحه من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي في هذا
السبب هل تبين لديكم اخيرا سيد لويس من
اعتدى على بعثتكم الدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم
عفوا هل تبين لديكم من اعتدى على موظفيكم
موظفي الاتحاد الاوروبي في ومكتبكم في
الخرطوم لا لا يكون واضح من المسؤول عن
ذلك
ليس لدينا معطياتها لهذا الموضوع وتم نقل
كل موظفين
شكرا جزيلا للسيد لويس ميغيل بوينو
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا لمت
ابعتي وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات